why wasn't the moon hungry because
it was full have you ever spent a day at
the beach
if yes then you must have observed the
variations in the level of the sea
near the shore this periodic rise and
fall of sea levels
are called tides when the water rises to
its highest level
covering much of the shore it's called a
high tide
and when the water falls to its lowest
level exposing the show
it's called low tide but have you ever
wondered
what causes these tights let's find that
out
in this q box video
[Music]
these tides are primarily caused by the
gravitational force of the moon
let's understand how
the earth can be imagined as sphere
surrounded by a layer of the ocean
and the moon as another sphere
we know that the earth and the moon are
attracted to each other because of
gravity
the moon exerts a gravitational pull on
the earth
on all its sides for instance
in this position the moon will not only
exert the pull at this point
but also here at the poles and also here
at the far end amazing isn't it
but we also know that the closer the two
objects are
the more is the gravitational pull they
experience
let's consider these three points a b
and c with b being the center of the
earth
now point a is closer to the moon in
comparison to point b
this means that the gravitational pull
acting at
a is stronger than that at b
hence the movement of point a towards
the moon
will be more than the movement of point
b
thus the water here will rise like this
leading to high tide at the same time
the gravitational pull acting at point b
that is the center of the earth
is greater than that at c hence
the movement of point b will be more
than the movement of point c
we can imagine it like this
this sphere moves leaving the water
behind leading to this bulge
or the rise in water level on this side
which is nothing
but a high tide this is how two high
tide regions
are formed one at a and the other
at c but how are low tides formed
we know that in the high tide regions
the water level rises
and bulges are formed but from where
does the extra water come to increase
the level
in the high tide regions actually
the water rushes out from these regions
as a result of which the water level
falls here
and creates low tide regions
in this way two high tides and two low
tides are formed during the day
now we know that the earth rotates
around its axis
thus the regions experiencing high tides
and low tides
keep on changing throughout the day with
the earth's rotation
with this we've uncovered the mystery
behind the formation of tides
but we know that the sun also exerts a
gravitational pull on the earth
so does the sun also cause the formation
of tides
well that's your q box to explore
do not forget to share your findings
with us in the comment section below
and if you've learned something new
today do share this video
with your friends and family bye